رار انتشار جيش الاحتلال على حاجز دير شرف
شمال غربي مدينه نابلس بعد تنفيذ عمليه
اطلاق نار عند هذا الحاجز ادت ستشهاد
فلسطيني بعد عمليه اطلاق النار حيث باشر
جيش الاحتلال بالانتشار بشكل مباشر صوب
هذا الحاجز واغلاق الحاجز امام
الفلسطينيين قوات الاحتلال دفعت بتعزيزات
عسكريه اسرائيليه جديده نحو هذا الحاجز من
كافه المحاور والمعسكرات القريبه من مدينه
نابلس حيث باشرت نجمه داوود الحمراء
بانتشال جثمان الشهيد واخذه الى جهه
مجهوله بعد عمليه اطلاق النار قوات
الاحتلال اغلقت الحاجز بشكل كامل هذا
الحاجز الذي يربط مدينه نابلس بمدينه طول
كرم وايضا جنين حيث انتشرت اليات الاحتلال
العسكريه واغلقت كافه الطرق المؤديه ومنعت
الفلسطينيين من الاقتراب قوات الاحتلال
منعت طواقم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني من
محاوله الوصول الى الشاب الذي اطلق النار
عليه وا ابقت على الارض حتى وصلت نجمه
داوود الحمراء هنا الصوره حيث لا يزال
الاحتلال يغلق كافه الطرق ويمنع
الفلسطينيين من الاقتراب من
هذه المنطقه قوات الاحتلال ايه اعدمت
الشاب ومنعت كافه الفلسطينيين
من الاقتراب منه ليرتفع عدد الشهداء منذ
السابع من اكتوبر الى ما يزيد عن
390 شهيدا
بواقع الاقتحامات
والاعتداءات اليوميه التي تشهدها مدن
الضفه الغربيه ليث جعار الجزيره دير شرف
فلسطين